[Música]
tras dos semanas de constantes ataques
rusos algunas zonas de mariupol quedaron
reducidas a escombros
estas imágenes de dron proporcionadas
por el regimiento ucraniano de extrema
derecha soft muestran edificios
residenciales en llamas
[Música]
este complejo de apartamentos acaba de
ser impactado por artillería pesada una
menor y ahora a su padre que continuaría
entre las ruinas
los residentes apenas tuvieron tiempo de
huir cuando el cielo volvió a retumbar
sobre sus cabezas el paso de los caza
rusos los volvió a mandar a resguardarse
en el interior
una pesadilla diaria muy difícil de
soportar
[Música]
no lo puedo aguantar más no tenemos
información no sabemos nada es como si
viviéramos en mitad de la nada podrían
al menos decirnos qué está pasando y
dónde sin teléfono ni internet los
residentes de mariupol están aislados
del mundo y no entienden por qué los
civiles son objetivos militares
esto era la escuela aquí estudiaban
niños pequeños no había soldados no
sabemos por qué
fuentes de la municipalidad informaron
que el último supermercado de mariupol
fue destruido hace unos días y que la
ciudad se ha quedado sin suministros
y no tenemos agua ni comida ni
electricidad
no tenemos calefacción y hace mucho frío
[Música]
si no recibimos ayuda nuestra gente
morirá en níjar y baile
según la alcaldía dos mil autos ya han
logrado salir de mariupol pero ningún
convoy humanitario pudo llegar a la
ciudad